[Music plays]
>>Rick Kleffel: Ladies and gentlemen, can
you please turn on your cell phones in case
you get a better offer.
[Laughter]
>>Rick Kleffel: Where you've come from is
gone.
Where you think you're going to never existed
and where you are is no good unless you can
get away.
Where is there a place for you to be?
Nowhere.
But if you've got a good search engine you
do not need to be redeemed.
Ladies and gentlemen, with us today we have
a man who works with the quantum level of
human communication.
We're standing in a tower that showcases the
enormous engines that we can bring to bear
to send atoms, molecules, electrons around
the world to bring two people together.
This is the man who works at the absolute
lowest level of human communication words.
His newest book is "This is How You Lose Her"
and he will give you a great instruction guide
to do just that.
[Laughter]
>>Rick Kleffel: His first book was the acclaimed
short story collection, "Drown" his Pulitzer
Prize winning novel was "The Brief, Wondrous
Life of Oscar Wao."
Ladies and gentlemen, please welcome Junot
Diaz.
[Applause]
>>Junot Diaz: Thank you.
I guess by way of like prefatory comments
thank you all for coming out.
We all know you all are busy.
I mean, gee whiz.
So, I appreciate you coming here in your spare
time.
I also wanted to thank Rick.
I'm actually a big old time fan of Rick's.
I have been following the Agony Columns since,
you know, a really long time.
I always enjoy when you're behind on reviews
and you're like, "I'm gonna dig up some old
review just to warm you dudes up."
[Laughter]
>>Junot Diaz: So it's a real pleasure to be
here.
It's a real pleasure and I thank all the people
who made this possible, again, you know, you
guys certainly understand that artists come,
they just appear but almost always it's a
bunch of people on the sideline doing the
stuff outside of their job description and
outside of their pay rate to bring people
like me around and I really appreciate and
wanna acknowledge that sort of invisible work
that makes these events possible.
And, again, thank you guys.
So, how do you wanna do this, Rick?
What are you thinking?
>>Rick Kleffel: I'm thinking you could read
the first chapter of the last story.
>>Junot Diaz: Okay, just a little brief reading,
I think, nothing-
>>Rick Kleffel: It's three pages, should take
a couple minutes.
>>Junot Diaz: Yeah.
I don't know if you guys-
>>Rick Kleffel: Utter brilliance.
>>Junot Diaz: That's highly doubtful but thank
you.
[Laughter]
>>Junot Diaz: Highly doubtful.
>>Rick Kleffel: There's a voice here that
you will never forget.
Reading him is like-
>>Junot Diaz: Damn you, Rick!
[Laughter]
>>Rick Kleffel: No, but remember the first
time you heard Aretha Franklin?
That voice coming out-
[Laughter]
>>Junot Diaz: Come on, Rick.
>>Rick Kleffel: This is the literary equivalent
of that.
[Laughter]
>>Junot Diaz: This is weed smoking, the consequences.
>>Junot Diaz: Young people, stay away from
it.
[Laughter]
>>Junot Diaz: For real this is what happens.
Come on, Rick.
Cut it out.
[Laughter]
>>Junot Diaz: This is like a banal second
person voice.
This is actually intentionally attempting
to get away from anything that would be remotely
considered attractive, you know?
So, I'm just gonna read it, second person,
it's a story called "The Cheater's Guide to
Love."
For those of you that are interested in narrative
you know the second person, as a form, sucks.
It's like kind of repellent.
Most of your experience with the second person
was as a young person.
The second person command form and totally
made you, hate, like, adults.
So, here we go.
"Year Zero.
Your girl catches you cheating.
Well actually, she's your fiancée.
But hey, in a bit it so won't matter.
She could have caught you with one sucia she
could've caught you with two but as you're
a totally [batched Guido] who didn't ever
empty his email trashcan, she caught you with
50.
Sure, over a 6 year period but still, 50 fucking
girls, God damn.
Maybe if you'd been engaged to a super open
minded blanquita you could have survived it."
[Laughter]
"But you're not engaged to a super open minded
blanquita, your girl is a badass [unintelligible]
who doesn't believe in open anything.
In fact, the one thing she warned you about
that she swore she would never forgive was
cheating.
'I'll put a machete in you' she promised."
[Laughter]
"And of course you swore you wouldn't do it,
you swore you wouldn't do it, you swore you
wouldn't and you did.
She'll stick around for a few months because
you dated for a long, long time, because you
went through much together; her father's death,
your tenure madness, her bar exam and because
love, real love, is not so easily shed.
Over a tortured six month period you will
fly to the DR, to Mexico, to New Zealand.
You will walk the beach where they filmed
'The Piano,' something she'd always wanted
to do and now, in penitent desperation, you
give it to her.
She is immensely sad on that beach and walks
up and down the shining sand alone, bare feet
in the freezing water and when you try to
hug her she says 'don't.'
She stares at the rocks jutting out of the
water, the wind taking her hair straight back.
On the ride back to the hotel up those wild
steeps, you pick up a pair of hitchhikers;
a couple so mixed it's ridiculous and so giddy
with love that you almost throw them out the
car."
[Laughter]
"She says nothing.
Later in the hotel she will cry.
You try every trick in the book to keep her,
you write letters, you drive her to work,
you quote Neruda, you compose a mass email
disowning all your sucias , you block their
emails, you change your phone numbers, you
stop drinking , you stop smoking, you claim
you're a sex addict and start attending meetings,
you blame your father, you blame your mother,
you blame the patriarchy, you blame Santo
Domingo, you find a therapist, you cancel
your Facebook, you give her the passwords
to all of your email accounts"
[Laughter]
"you start taking salsa classes like you always
swore you would so the two of you could dance
together, you claim that you were sick, you
claim that you were weak, it was the book,
it was the pressure and every hour like clockwork
you say that you're so, so sorry.
You try it all but one day she will simply
sit up in bed and say, 'No more' and yeah,
and you will have to move from the Harlem
apartment the two of you have shared.
You consider not going, you consider a squat
protest, in fact, you say you won't go but
in the end you do.
For awhile you haunt the city like a two bit
ball player waiting for a call up.
You phone her every day and leave messages
which she doesn't answer.
You write her long sensitive letters which
she returns unopened.
You even show up at her apartment at odd hours
and at her job downtown until finally her
little sister calls you, the one who was always
on your side, and she makes it plain.
'If you try to contact my sister again she's
going to put a restraining order on you.'
For some Negros that wouldn't mean shit but
you ain’t that kind of a Negro.
You stop; you move back to Boston, you never
see her again."
That's all, thank you.
[Applause]
>>Rick Kleffel: They're a foreign species
aren't they?
They look like-
>>Junot Diaz: Dudes.
>>Rick Kleffel: They have the same DNA as
us but they're a completely different species.
>>Junot Diaz: Oh, I thought you meant men.
[Laughter]
>>Junot Diaz: Men, even those of us who are
men know that we are like an alien unto ourselves
which is sort of an outcome of our encourage
not to have much internal scrutiny.
Yeah.
>>Rick Kleffel: You know, one of the things
that I just reread the "Brief Wondrous Life
of Oscar Wao"
>>Junot Diaz: Rick.
[Laughter]
>>Rick Kleffel: I had to.
>>Junot Diaz: Come on man.
>>Rick Kleffel: It was so much fun and one
of the things that really knocked me out about
that book was the way you use, you engage
in what any science fiction reader would called
world building.
For those of us who have never been to the
Dominican Republic or don't know anything
about that and immigrant experience and you
use, you create that world by using, in part,
the language of fans of world building fiction.
>>Junot Diaz: Sure.
>>Rick Kleffel: And I think that was such
an interesting decision to do that.
Tell us a little bit just about creating that
kind of character and the, your fascination
with that kind of literature.
>>Junot Diaz: No, it's a really great observation,
Rick.
I mean, one of the things I teach at MIT is
I teach a class for, of world building for
various narrative media so I have kids that,
like, wanna do comic books, I got kids that
are working on computer games, kids who are
working on film, kids who are doing pen and
paper stuff doing, like, fiction.
So, you know, each of these kinds of mediums
have their different affordances but world
buildings a sort of essential component of
this stuff.
What interested me very deeply was that all
of us go about worlds where we kind of take
them for granted, that old sort of super brainy
word that, our doxa, like what we, our common
place, the thing that we don’t even think
about.
But if you're gonna do any kind of art and
tell any kind of story you have to produce
the world where your characters and your conflicts
are set.
Even if it's the real world, you have to produce
it, you have to create it, you have to world
build.
Most of us don't notice world building in
what we would call straight fiction, like
what we would call literary fiction or mainstream
fiction but, of course, it's occurring.
So what interested me really deeply was I
grew up reading a ton of science fiction,
a ton of fantasy, a ton of horror, genres
where world building is what is used to heighten
and contextualize the conflict, right?
We know that for horror most explicitly that
horror tends to use all these gothic cues
and all this kind of gothic settings so that
we know that there's gonna be some horrible
thing that's gonna happen and all sorts of
terrible kind of dangers and monsters are
much more possible because the world sort
of, you know, leads us into a very unsteady
terrain where monstrosity seems not to be
an exception but almost an inevitability.
And what happens with me is I become obsessed
with reading all these books and I notice
that there is almost no difference between
Jane Eyre rendering her world, yeah, a world
that she knew completely, we're talking about
the narrative presence, she knew completely
well but still she went out of her way to
make sure she explained the world for readers.
Yeah, versus a Tolkien who is in some ways
the raison d'être, you know, he's like the
most important of our concept as traditional
world builders where he goes out of his way
to explain middle earth and I realized that
any story worth reading requires, or worth
engaging in or worth playing with, requires
the world to be communicated efficiently and
in many ways, as beautifully as possible.
So the Dominican Republic, something I know
incredibly well and Central New Jersey, another
place I know incredibly well,
[Laughter]
>>Junot Diaz: I mean, anybody, Jersey?
>>audience members: Yeah!
>>Junot Diaz: Yes?
[Laughter]
>>Junot Diaz: Where in Jersey?
>>audience member: Montgomery
>>Junot Diaz: Oh yeah, man.
I delivered pool tables there.
[Laughter]
>>Junot Diaz: That's cool, that's cool, man.
Anyone from Santo Doming at all?
>>male: Here.
>>Junot Diaz: Yes!
[Laughter]
>>Junot Diaz: We're always, there's always
one of us.
[Laughter]
>>Junot Diaz: [unintelligible Spanish], man.
>>Junot Diaz: So I realized that the part
of what I knew so well I had to render it,
you know, I had to create it and, again, the
cues of good world building, for me, I just
felt it was like a natural to just use fantasy,
science fiction, horror, as a way to show
how there is almost no difference and, in
fact, they're drawing on the same grammars.
>>Rick Kleffel: It's, it really makes the
world so vivid for us and one of the things,
too, that I see in all of your fiction and
all your stories there's a really unique sense
of the voice in story, anything you tell us
is crafted in prose and in voice that is so
compelling we are just grabbed from the first
sentence and held riveted till whatever the
hell you're saying ends and it doesn't even
matter.
And if I were to describe "The Brief Wondrous
Life of Oscar Wao" to myself I could describe
it in a way I'd say, "I'd never read a book
like that" but then when I sit down and read
it I am instantly linked.
I'd like you to just talk a little bit about
discovering that voice and, you know, creating
the Yunior of the Rings Trilogy.
>>Junot Diaz: Yeah, no, thank you.
You know part of this, Rick, comes from sort
of a strategy that you need as a story teller,
I mean, especially guys if you're trying to
do any kind of ideological work which anyone
who's telling stories is even they're not
doing it consciously, you know, part of telling
a story is that you're in some ways pitching
an ethos, you know, it's just the nature,
it comes out of it.
But, for me, I tend to be really interested
in topics that people have huge resistances
to talking about.
So I'm really interested in, sort of, the
long term consequences of rape, you know,
I'm interested in what it means to live in
the shadow of a dictatorship.
I'm interested in stuff like how race and
racism and self hatred organize a sexual economy.
I mean, we like to think that we just fall
in love but people fall in love in pretty
predictable terms along the racial economy.
So I'm interested in all this stuff but people
don't ever wanna talk about this shit.
I mean, my MIT students, I'll be like, "Is
there any race issues at MIT?" and they're
like, "None!"
[Laughter]
>>Junot Diaz: Right?
They're like, "None!" and I'm like, "Really?
Huh?"
I was like, "There seems to be a lot of Asian
girls with white dudes."
[Laughter]
>>Junot Diaz: And suddenly it's like the thing
that you weren't supposed to say, you weren't
supposed to talk about this stuff and suddenly
they're just, their brains are gripped by
this silence.
And I think that we have a lot of resistance
to talk about things that we observe everyday
and, so, I think part of the work that occurs
with Yunior's voice isn't simply because you're
like looking for a nice voice so that people
will read the book, I need something heavy
duty to misdirect the reader so that they
will read a book about the consequences of
rape, the consequences of how we seem to fall
in love in ways that Adolf Hitler would be
pleased and that also on top of that, that
like a lot of us are haunted, deeply haunted
by all sorts of both family, personal and
often national histories which we don't even
recognize and a lot of stuff people ain't,
you bring this shit up, I talk to my students
about it and that's the thing in class my
students can't wait to get off.
They're just like, "Yo, don't talk to me about
how everybody I date is lighter skinned than
me.
I wanna do it; I don't wanna talk about it."
[Laughter]
>>Junot Diaz: "Don't talk about how I, we
all exoticize Asian women in a certain way.
We just wanna do it but don't bring it up."
[Laughter]
>>Junot Diaz: And I think part of what happens
when you create these sort of books where
you're trying to wrestle with these issues
is that you need this sort of, what we call,
ledger domain, you need this kind of sleight
of hand so that people are lured into the
conversation without them even knowing they're
in there.
And that's the plan, it never works, I'm not
kidding, it never works.
It's a gesture towards a strategy.
>>Rick Kleffel: You know, it strikes me that
in a sense that you're a horror fiction writer
because you're writing about the things that
we're scared to even know.
It's very crafty in that sense.
>>Junot Diaz: No question.
And how often, I mean first it's a nice comparison,
I'm like-
[Laughter]
>>Junot Diaz: But how accurate it is I don't
know.
But sort of that's kind of a, a kind of punning
into meaning.
Part of what we all do as artists, I mean,
the reason, guys we're in the middle of an
election campaign, you all notice that neither
of our possible oppressors-in-chief
[Laughter]
>>Junot Diaz: that neither of them have mentioned
an artist?
You can go through a whole campaign- say?
>>audience member: [inaudible]
[Laughter]
>>Junot Diaz: Yeah.
Right, right.
If that was Clint Eastwood that was as close
as we come to discussing art.
[Laughter]
>>Rick Kleffel: And we're back in the horror
genre.
[Laughter]
>>Junot Diaz: Yeah I know!
>>Junot Diaz: That was like, I don't know
about you but I literally had one of those
weird moments where I was watching that and
I was like, "Did I start smoking crack and
never tell myself?"
[Laughter]
>>Junot Diaz: Cause you're like, "What the
hell?"
[Laughter]
>>Junot Diaz: So-
>>Rick Kleffel: It was a media drum moment.
>>Junot Diaz: My God.
My God.
But, so, you know, part of the reason this
is always happening is because in our culture,
the thing with artists is that artists are
just fundamentally attracted to the things
that no one is trying to deal with.
I mean, that's what art's nature is.
It immediately goes for a silence, you know,
immediately goes for an absence.
So it's not a bad thing to do it just means
you have to have a certain constitution for
it, you know, and it's, you know, like you
said, it's a bit of a horror story for both
the artist and for the people because it's
not as if the average artist gets any pleasure
at bringing stuff up that other people resist.
I mean, for real, rare is the artist who goes
to bed thinking, "Aha, I have been transgressive.
I feel great."
[Laughter]
>>Junot Diaz: Usually it costs, you know,
it's not just self validation, it usually
costs an artist just as much to break these
kind of force fields but I think those of
us who are drawn to be an artist, we know
this is important, we know that we're in service
of a larger cause, so, you do it.
>>Rick Kleffel: When you're sitting down to,
your stories have so much insight and it's
a really interesting insight into the way
that men and women talk to one another because
it's influenced by absence.
What we see is somebody who is abs-, you give
us somebody who is absolutely clueless in
many ways as to what his, what effects his
actions are going to have.
And, after awhile, at first you're just going,
"Oh, this is pretty funny" and then after
awhile you're just thinking, "Oh, wait.
Oh wait."
>>Junot Diaz: Yeah, no, it's true.
I mean, I think that privilege requires an
operational cluelessness.
[Laughter]
>>Junot Diaz: You know, I think it's no accident
that Yunior is completely blithely unaware
of what his masculinity in his relationships
to women does.
You know, I mean, I think it's, in fact, in
many ways is part of his legacy.
I think, again, it's one of those things where
Yunior's cluelessness is what always, the
consequences of operating in a world where
you have privilege is you quickly begin to
realize that the energy it takes for you not
to notice what you're doing begins to slowly
eat at you.
You know, and I think that, you know, it takes,
I'm telling you it takes a lot of effort to
sit around and pretend that you're not harming
anyone, to pretend that you're not predatory.
I mean, no one likes to think of ourselves
as predatory but the nature of privilege is
that you're predatory and I think that if
you have any kind of a soul or any kind of
compassionate soul it creates all this kind
of contradictions in you, it begins to eat
at you.
And I always think like, "God, when I grow
up" when I was growing up most of what I was
learning as a young man in a super masculine
culture, I came from a military parent, my
little brother is a combat veteran, marine
combat veteran, my sister was married into
the army, my two nephews served in Iraq.
My family was like seriously military family.
What I noticed is a lot of this shit that
we were learning as boys, as men, was how
to manage our masculinity.
Like what we would do to take the bite off
of that slowly devouring recognition and it
wears you out.
>>Rick Kleffel: I'd like to invite the audience
to ask some questions.
[Laughter]
>>Rick Kleffel: before you and I spend the
next three hours up here dweeby nerding.
[Laughter]
>>Junot Diaz: Well we're gonna fuckin' do
the worm on you guys.
[Laughter]
>>Rick Kleffel: There's a gentleman in a green
shirt right there.
>>Junot Diaz: That's you, sir.
>>male #1: Oh, hi.
>>Junot Diaz: Oh, that's what you were doing.
You're so good, bro.
[Laughter]
>>Junot Diaz: They got you-
>>Rick Kleffel: Oh, here we go.
>>male #1: So I am a Boricua from Newark New
Jersey, Boricua Puerto Rican for anybody who
doesn't-
>>Junot Diaz: Where North New Jersey?
>>male #1: Newark New Jersey.
>>Junot Diaz: Oh, Newark.
>>male #1: Yeah, yeah.
>>Junot Diaz: I spend a lot of time in Newark.
>>male #1: Yeah, my parents went to Rutgers
where you were an undergrad, I just graduated
from Cornell where you got your Master's of
Fine Arts; I read your Wikipedia page, of
course.
[Laughter]
>>Junot Diaz: Damn you.
>>male #1: Yeah and I just wanted to know
how much, you know, I'm a big fan of your
writing.
Last time when I was an intern at the Hispanic
Googler's Network, I started a book group
and the book we read was "The Brief Wondrous
Life of Oscar Wao" and I was wondering how
much of your, how much of your writing is
giving insight to those that don't know what
it's like to grow up as an urban Latino youth?
And how much of it is, you know, writing for
the Latino population and being that, being
that, you know, that author that everyone
knows as standing up as an example and a model
for other aspiring Latino writers?
>>Junot Diaz: Yeah, that's a wonderful question.
You know, I think part of what, what one begins
to understand when one, especially a reader,
is that most of us are not exposed to a culture
where our experiences are narrativized.
Where, in other words, we're mysteries unto
ourselves especially if you come from a background
like say an immigrant background or a Latino
background.
Often enough we don't really have any language
to explain who the hell we are.
We don't have like 200 narratives that explain
how we get here.
You know what I mean?
And I think that often I am not writing so
that, for example, other people understand
what this experience is, I'm writing so that
I understand what this experience is.
And in that way it sort of opens up by being
incredibly particular, you know, creating
a space of deliberation for someone like me,
it opens up that universal, sort of, door
where anyone who's interested in this experience
can sort of connect to it.
I mean, again, I remember when I first read
a book by someone of African descent.
I mean, we live in a country where you can
actually say this, I remember my first book
about the African Diaspora.
I'm from the African Diaspora.
It wasn't until I read this book that I suddenly
began to see and understand myself in a totally
different way because many of us, again, we
live in a culture where we are in a culture
and we are ghosts.
There is nothing in that culture that helps
us understand ourselves.
There's nothing on TV, there's nothing in
books, there's nothing in the larger sort
of universe that gives us any insight into
our own experience.
So I guess that's my approach, my approach
is that usually I'm writing to kind of explain
this experience to myself through my characters
but that guarantees that anyone who's interested
and who enjoys it will also join me on the
same exploration.
As far as the last part of it, you know, again
it's you're an artist and you know that you're
coming out of a community, I'm coming out
of a Dominican, African Diasporic, Caribbean,
military, Jersey and a million other spaces
background, you know, nerd, whatever.
I guess, I'm aware that as a writer, as an
artist my presence is really just what I would
call a marker of absence.
The fact that I'm a Dominican writer just
speaks to how many thousands of Dominican
writers we don't have and need.
The fact that I'm like a Caribbean writer
explains, for me, it's more I'm standing in
for how many more stories we need.
I don't think I represent anyone but I think
I a marker of a great unhappy absence.
So, there's other hands, yeah.
>>female #1: I don't think this is working.
>>Junot Diaz: It is.
>>female #1: Okay, so you mentioned, you said
that you think of privilege as predatory and
that it eats away and you're using masculinity
as an example, do you see, do you apply that
to something like white privilege as opp-,
which I never thought of as eating away at
anyone since they're kind of unaware of it
and do you feel qualified to write about it.
Obviously masculinity is something you write
about and maybe feel qualified as a man but
writing about that in terms of race issues
as opposed to gender issues where you're not
white, I don’t know, I just wonder how you,
is that an analogy that you can also apply
to white privilege?
>>Junot Diaz: Without any question.
I mean, I feel like we often, again, the training
we get in this country is that we rarely get
a starter course on white supremacy.
[Laughter]
>>Junot Diaz: But I think it's very important
for us to have a starter course on white supremacy
because we tend to think that-
>>Rick Kleffel: It's American history 101.
>>Junot Diaz: Yeah.
[Laughter]
>>Junot Diaz: But we also tend to think that
white supremacy is a discussion of white people.
White supremacy doesn't, if you think, guys
if you really think that white people are
running white supremacy, that's crazy.
They can't do the work to run it.
I think that the nature is that white supremacy
is in every single person in the system.
So that someone like me in the Dominican Republic,
all I have to do is take you into one of our
pharmacies and show you all the skin lightening
creams, show you all the horrors that people
inflict on their skin to try to match a white
ideal.
You don't even need white people to practice
white supremacy; in fact, it works best when
there's actually not a large collective of
white folks around.
I mean, I think that white supremacy is a
force, it's sort of a gravitational force,
in almost all the cul- not in almost, in all
the cultures of what we call the new world.
And I certainly am very much interested in
this I mean my characters are aware even within
their group of how lightness as a privilege
and darkness is something to be avoided or
at least to be thought of in certainly particularly
deformed ways like, you know, a certain kind
of darkness in males becomes hyper sexualized
and darkness in females becomes a desirable
mulata.
But, again, I think that this is something
that eats at all of us because think about
how white supremacy has divided folks from
a real sense of communion with each other.
You know, and how it has just damaged communities.
I mean, I don't know if you've seen the figures
of how many billions of dollars worldwide
are being spent by people trying to burn their
skin pale.
So I guess for me it's the same thing, it's
a, any kind of privilege is a predator that
eats at us, you know, but I always say to
my students, I'm like, "You can take every
single damn white person on the earth, put
them on a spaceship, send them out and we
will keep white supremacy running fully well.
Yeah, in China, try to be a black person trying
to teach English in China.
You can't get a job.
I had a student went to China tried to teach
English and they're like; "We only want white
people."
So I think that this is something that is
important and as an artist I'm just drawn
to it.
>>male #2: Hi, so I was reading the new bio
of Dave Foster Wallace recently and there
was a lot of talk about various author's thoughts
on the contemporary state of literature and
like really consciously writing with an ethos
like [unintelligible name] and Franzen saying
we have to return to literature's roots and
paraphrasing, it's unlikely that anyone with
a computer at their job is writing good fiction.
And since you're at Google and you teach at
MIT, I'm wondering if you have like maybe
thoughts on that particular statement but
generally on like the role of fiction in an
increasingly like Twitterized world.
>>Junot Diaz: Sure, yeah, do I have any, like,
stupendously unhelpful generalizations
[Laughter]
>>Junot Diaz: It's really what it is because,
well no because really what it is, it's so
strange to hear authors talk about the state
of American fiction.
Guys, I read a book, this is what I do for
a living, I read a book every two or three
days, you know what I'm saying, like I'm a
herb like that.
But I have probably read .00001 percent of
American literature.
For me to draw any conclusions on my reading
about what's going on in American literature,
Franzen has shown no awareness, I totally
respect the guy, but he's shown no awareness
of what women writers are up to, I've never
heard him ever mention a writer of color,
ever.
I mean, he doesn't seem to have any awareness
of what the other America's writing.
I'm not sure that we understand well what's
happening in any artistic pursuit.
Now, are there certain tendencies?
Certainly, but I wonder if our descriptions
of our art don't reveal mostly our ignorance
of what's going on on the ground.
And, again, I'm not so sure, I mean, certainly
we're being dispersed and atomized and our
attention is being multiply divided by this
kind of world which is asking us to constantly
consult a machine every three seconds to kind
of feel normal but we've been under weirder
conditions before and we've produced enormous
art.
You know, I think that the challenges are
real.
Living in this pace that we live now is a
real challenge not to be dismissed but I guess
I have an enormous faith because I come from
a community that has come out of worse situations
than this and has produced most of the culture
that we call American and is quite beautiful.
So I guess in my mind I think that we're not
as bad as people make us look.
And our resistances to these kind of forces
is certainly valiant but the reality of the
forces raised against us cannot be under,
you know, undervalued.
And I don't know, I just, I guess I'm a utopian,
I really believe that writing inside of a
problem often generates answers.
And that from sitting up top and saying that
we need to return to, what literature are
we going to return to?
[Laughter]
>>Junot Diaz: I'm like; Franzen is the whitest
white, white, white, white, white.
[Laughter]
>>Junot Diaz: He wants to return to what,
the 70's when it was white, white, white,
white, white, white?
[Laughter]
>>Junot Diaz: I mean, I don't know, I don't
know what utopian past there is where things
are better.
We're jacked up, we're human, we take both
our hands intuitively, put them around our
own necks and try to choke ourselves to death,
we just do it naturally.
And the nature of us is also to try to fight
that.
So, I don't know, I mean, no disrespect to
my fellow writers but the reality is it's
tough but you young people are always up to
the challenge, you surprise us.
Madam?
Oh, no you had a mic, sir please and then
we'll pass it over.
>>male #3: Sure.
No problem, is this on?
Alright.
Well I think the answer to your question is
Ralph Waldo Emerson, right?
That's where we wanna go.
[Laughter]
>>Junot Diaz: Enough said.
>>male #3: but actually we, you know, here,
I'm a sort of digital humanist and so we have
a few things going on here that are kind of
interesting which I'd be happy to talk about
maybe later or something at Ngram Viewer where
we're actually able to look over like millions
of books and kind of get, at least from a
linguistic level, and idea of what might be
going on currently which is kind of interesting.
But I have a more important question to ask
you which is we were talking about privilege
and you said you teach at MIT, that's correct?
So, and I was wondering cause you mentioned
earlier that neither of the presidential candidates
have really mentioned art, artists, humanities,
what you think from your position of privilege
of being at MIT cause it's not exactly like
a regular liberal arts school funding wise,
what you think that people can do to promote
the arts and humanities?
What is there, I mean other than just speaking
out because, obviously, you know, the way
we're going and we're at Google right which
the stem fields get all the funding, right,
so what do you think is possible for us to
do?
>>Junot Diaz: Yeah.
>>male #3: To support art.
>>Junot Diaz: No, I think it's a wonderful
question and I think, you know, what's funny
about MIT is that MIT for me is just emblematic
of the larger culture.
Meaning MIT just makes more explicit stuff
that's being said all across America and usually
all across America they're saying art is frivolous
or it's utterly irrelevant.
And MIT just sort of makes that sense more
explicit.
They're like, "We're too busy doing this other
stuff so we don't need this."
You know, but it's the same kind of general
argument.
I think in the end we're always stuck in a
situation where the promotion of art is a
grass roots movement.
When I hear Republicans talking about a faith
based initiative, to believe in arts and to
believe that communities deserve art is literally
a faith based initiative.
Because in the sort of economy we live now
where everything has to show black, everything
has to be like well what's the economic outcome
of it?
Art doesn't correspond to this at all, at
all.
So our logic of this sort of way that the
world works and sort of leaves art out of
it but, again, there's a billion strategies
most of us are pursuing it, you know, people
form book groups, yeah, people go see movies
occasionally.
You know, people like TV shows and have conversations
about them.
The real thing, for me, when I'm at MIT is
that my goal at a place like that, yeah, for
me MIT is like when I immigrated to the United
States I immediately entered the top notch
privilege in the world.
So going to MIT was paled to my immigration
to the US.
You know, that was real privilege.
MIT, eh, but what I felt that my absolute
role at a place like MIT is to champion the
centrality and fundamental importance to art
in a place where it's really you against everybody.
But there also is so many allies; you'd be
amazed how many people, given the chance to
support art, will.
And it's, it's a fight we have to do and before
it used to be like, you know, we have to have
our civil rights, we have to have our civic
engagement but certainly we've come to a place
now where our sort of social ecology has made
art very, very threatened and we all have
to push and there's a billion strategies.
You know, me, I go into the students and model
my excitement, my enthusiasm and that's not
a small thing because if you convince an MIT
student that art is essential to their well
being and to their practice you've flipped
a person who otherwise never would have been
flipped and you just gotta do it that way.
Other people do it other ways, you have these
meetings here but the battle is long but our
love for the arts is more powerful.
I mean, that's the thing.
We all love a certain kind of art and that's
the thing that keeps us going despite the
desert of our social moment.
>>Rick Keffel: We're a narrative species and
that's why stories are so important to us.
We, if I ask any one of you people here who
you are, you're going to tell me a story.
>>Junot Diaz: Yeah.
>>Rick Keffel: So we all need to know about
that.
Last question.
>>female #2: Okay, so my question is actually
about genre fiction.
You mentioned that you read a lot of science
fiction and fantasy when you were growing
up and I also did and one of the things that
I noticed was that the future was very white.
In reading, especially science fiction, certainly
reading fantasy was just a little different
because of that incredible nostalgia for a
certain type of whiteness.
So I'm wondering if you're still reading in
that genre and how you feel about the feel
today and also since you used so many tropes
of the kind of genre fiction if you've thought
about expanding your writing into that arena?
>>Junot Diaz: Yeah, I wrote and published
a science fiction story like a couple months
ago called "Monstro" which appeared in the
New Yorker, it's kind of an alien virus giant
monster invasion story.
Look, I, the genre is shifting very, very
swiftly.
You have all sorts of new practitioners, you
know, M.K. Jameson, you've got all these interesting
people of color writing, sort of giving us,
giving the future I think a much more realistic
view but what's interesting about even the
whitest white science fiction or fantasy future
is that it's extraordinary how some of the
preoccupations that don't appear in realistic
fiction take over genre fiction.
For example, I come from a country haunted
by an American backed dictatorship.
The average American is not aware of how much
we love to fund dictatorships and the sort
of immense impact that has.
The average American, if you guys are not
in the military you don't, or don't have a
military family, you have no idea what the
American military looks like at a global level.
Those of us who are in military families,
we're like, we have a totally different sense
of a map.
Realistic fiction doesn't do a good job of
that.
But you read science fiction and fantasy and
there's stuff in there about genocide, about
slavery, about the breeding of human beings
which if you're of African descent in this
hemisphere that's your legacy, you were bred
into existence.
Usually raped but it was a breeding project
of form.
And there were questions of power, of how
a dictator, of one person with an immense
amount of power, so while the future often,
not more than often, is predominantly white,
a lot of the issues that people are wrestling
with are sort of the taboos that realistic
literature doesn't like to address.
So the one can recuperate even from the whitest
narrative, some interesting things but what
really I'm excited about is how many young,
brown colored nerds are out there beginning
to totally transform the field and there's
a bunch of young people that are coming out
and that I'm like really, really excited about.
Again, I don't know if I'll ever be able to
really write a full science fiction book because
it actually, its way hard, man.
[Laughter]
>>Junot Diaz: But I wouldn't mind doing it,
you know, you'll always have, if you have
a young love, if you like love tennis there's
always a part of you that wants to like, "I
wanna win a competition" or "I wanna play
somebody" You know?
So there's some of that.
[Laughter]
>>Junot Diaz: But I keep reading it, I keep
reading it.
I mean I love these Filipino brothers who,
these 'Pino brothers who write this comic
book, the Luna brothers, I don't know if you
know them.
Really fantastic young brothers, they're 'Pino
and they write an under image comic.
They've written some wonderful books, "Girls"
"The Sword" and, again, I think its happening
but we have to look for it.
>>Rick Kleffel: Ladies and gentlemen, I'd
like to thank you for your time and for coming
here and joining us today.
Please welcome and say thank you to our guest.
[Applause]